[Applaudissements]
les sélectionneurs benoît le bris
c'est ça
c'est ça vous le voyez le vendredi dans
le mcg en acadie il a été tellement bon
vendredi dernier qu on lui a dit
qu'aujourd'hui on le voulait avec nous
et c'est vrai que vous êtes formidable
vraiment bon on verra après peut-être
aussi plus un secret mais je préfère le
dire maintenant c'est avant tout un ami
je vous le dis papa d'une petite fille
doit les un concert ce soir juste après
ses congés annuels et ingénieur vous
avez coupé le divorce à mon niveau femme
va divorcer à cause de vous non c'est un
oui parce que j'ai dis pas je pouvais
pas alors je prends en charge tous les
divorces halde
j'ai pris les clubs de castres mais naim
si je dois te payer en boulettes
inquiète pas alors aujourd'hui je suis
que tu es venu en plus pour me démonté
la gueule pas du tout pas du tout en
fait je l'expliquais de là je suis ravi
de retrouver tous les meilleurs
chroniqueurs du monde et bernard montiel
[Rires]
alors je suis venu parce qu'en fait je
tombais sur un truc incroyable
aujourd'hui vous savez que tous les
matins je mange mes tartines au regard
en termes de jean pierre elkabbach jean
synnex de notre amie christine kelly
bien sûr c'est un des plus grands
journalistes
ah oui de l'histoire de france et un
truc dont mes critiques en rien de
france télévisions et bien sûr et art
autant pendant des années année vous
allez comprendre pourquoi j'ai été très
surpris regard des très bons invités de
jean pierre elkabbach c'est ça brice
hortefeux bonjour bonjour bienvenue
président philippe balasse merci d'être
avec nous dans read le pen bonjour merci
d'être avec nous et ce matin l'invité
c'était soyez le bienvenu vous êtes le
bienvenu chez elle elle anime bonjour
merci bonjour dos il était 7 heures 20
j'avais la gueule en biais souvent
j'avais date est assemblée la sélection
devait opposer mais qu'est ce qu'on
faisait 7 heures 24 mai sur la scène
madame et même moi je sais même pas ce
que je veux a sapé depuis que j'ai eue
contre aunis courjault il ya quinze ans
j'ai jamais eu de noda 7h24 si vous êtes
dedans et vous êtes en réunion d'habitue
l'ancien oui j'ai la photo d'ailleurs de
la réunion d'habitude réunion alors
l'arrivée de cyril hanouna sur s'est
vite ce matin c'était vraiment ces news
en alertant que c'était sur ces news
pardon c'était emmanuel macron qui
arrive à ces news quoi c'était fou bon
là c'était plus mails makrouds
évidemment mais regardez vous allez voir
alors il ya même le big boss de canal
gérald brice viret qui est là pour les
accueillir alors c'est la première fois
de sa vie que le patron se lève pour
[Rires]
ah mais c'est vrai il avait jean pierre
elkabbach
il m'a dit écoute moi bien on a reçu
tous les ministres est jamais loupé sa
[Rires]
mairie gérald le gal a mis la cravate et
tout judic jura sera moi je suis venu en
cas d'edf tu vois pour relever les
compteurs mais vous devez en dehors de
l'argent je pense n'y avait non c'est
pas possible
alors moi je me sens fier et collages
ladmirault couche le j'aime beaucoup ses
rimes savez pourquoi parce qu'en fait il
partie d'un cas d'éric des gens comme
moi qui n'ont plus de cheveux vous savez
ouais ils laissent pousser sur le côté
ouais pour ravad comme ça et il pense
que personne ne le remarque à mes
jean-pierre on l'adorent mais il a une
chez elles par de rares et fait tout
pour que ces vaches mais on adore ces
menaces a italienne ça a tout dit et a
pas trop ça aurait en fait il a un
budget qui tourne comme as en battant
face si vous accueilli à bras ouverts
cyril regarder la preuve que maintenant
vous êtes le bienvenu si elle est là
nous là bonjour merci bonjour
de quoi je me mêle
[Rires]
et ça m'a dit qu'on avait de quoi je me
mêle
alors retour normal c'est en direct se
répartit en cacahuète et là j'ai su me
maîtriser non maîtrisée alors plus sympa
comme accueil c'est vrai que je vois pas
ce qui allait être qu'est ce qu'il faut
là espèce de tarbes à pourquoi un
pakistanais j'ai pas demandé de rose
chez vous si vous êtes donné une très
bonne réponse on va la voir tout de
suite regardez moi cette réponse de quoi
je me mêle
je me mêle je me mêle comme tous les
français de ce qui nous regarde
[Applaudissements]
j'ai répondu très bien répondu je trouve
c'est oui il faut quand même pas mal d'à
propos l'appareil y'a pas mieux alors
c'est vrai que ça sur comment 30 minutes
la france a constaté jean pierre
elkabbach vous aimez beaucoup
ouais ouais ouais on regarde moi du
divertissement et de bouffonnerie cyril
hanouna deviennent staline un cirque et
guignol gaudriole les dérapages
xénophobes misogyne et sexiste je suis
insupportable donc c'est très difficile
de coanimer avec moi mais c'est bien
marc coma c'est vrai que quand on voit
un truc rendu compte 7 il a été
extrêmement sérieux jusqu'à la fin non
je l'attrapé
voilà du bon quand ça coûte moins cher
que d'acheter gentil jamais le pack
ouais mais tu vas voir non mais énorme
et c'est normal c'est le jeu sinon
l'addition s'il avait d'ailleurs ils
voient crédibilise beaucoup c'est très
bien ce qu'il a à faire et bien sûr non
ils vont prendre de faire d'abou
fonderies de fer de la gaudriole déjà
c'est n'importe quoi
mais il est allé encore plus loin ça
m'énerve et regardez moi ces gens qui
viennent veulent aller dans le même sens
et veulent faire avancer les choses
donc la confrontation oui oui les
blagues salaces
non mais alors c'est vraiment c'est mal
vous connaître wes lorsque les blagues
salaces en fait jamais dans ses vrais
aller dans ce qui se veut non voilà quoi
il y avait le feu dans ta tous
[Applaudissements]
c'est dépassé alors hier soir c'était la
première de la scoumoune mêmes jeux
d'arcade comme on dit dans le nord de la
tunisie et m'a fait penser à cette
personne pendant tout le jeu à sept
personnes portées disparues la gaffe
tout le jeu non mais c'est vrai c'était
en bourse 90e nenê et park lagaf tient
un bowling maintenant il paraît et
laveries shoukoum comment ce serait
d'autres oublient de regarder toutes les
émissions stéphane bern
ça serait un peu compliqué et travaille
avec caroline ithurbide dans le type
l'agglo car oui mais vous l'adorez mois
l'a pas beaucoup vu pendant la soirée et
franchement c'est wenger parce que j'ai
un peu peur que karine ferri porte
plainte pour plagiat
non c'est un chien très bien démarré
mais on lâche comme une balance ton post
vous savez tout faire vous êtes le roi
des rois du grand écart comme le prouve
cette photo a longtemps regardé la
différence boulot à nous mettre ses news
et le and that's était venu je pense
politique monsieur elkabbach et là je
pense que c'est juste voilà c'est des
manoeuvres politiques
pire après
moi je ne fais pas de politique monsieur
elkabach je me souviens de notre grand
écart c'était le 9 novembre dernier ce
que vous rappelez du 9 novembre dernier
dans votre vie mans qui s'est passé et
bien écoutez vous aviez enchaîné dans la
même soirée des séquences un peu
différente et c'était du grand art
chérie je lis l'avenir dans le cassoulet
et engrais à quai nous n'aurions alors
les chéris c'est le premier débat de la
soirée est pour ou contre l'euthanasie
c'est le premier match où selon closer
si tu fais d'un petit arbre à
l'hébergement me le dit souvent
alors et vous voyez ce matin en
regardant sur ses news je vous ai
découvert nouveau un cyril hanouna
sensible un cyril hanouna penseur il
hanouna mystique
ce qu'on voit plein de gens qui se
retrouvent du jour au lendemain la rue
des travailleurs qui se retrouvent à la
rue
j'ai envie voilà d'aider les gens qui
souffrent on voudrait tout ce qu on
serre les coudes et qu'on essaie
d'avancer dans le même sens je pense que
tout le monde doit tendre la main à ceux
qui sont les plus démunis
[Musique]
j'ai pu voir pour finir justement
désormais syrie je pense que votre
avenir est tout tracé mois dans dix ans
que shadow je vous vois nous avions à sa
place chez moi à sa place à lui regarder
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]